Salut les Épicurieuses et les Épicurieux !
Le trésor des Templiers, je suis sûr que
vous en avez tous entendu parler.
La légende raconte qu'il serait composé
de pièces d'or, de pierres précieuses
et de bijoux d'une valeur inestimable.
Depuis plus de 9 siècles,
personne n'a encore réussi
à mettre la main dessus.
Alors aujourd'hui, moi aussi
j'ai décidé de partir à sa recherche.
Et vous allez voir,
les pistes ne manquent pas.
Certains parmi vous
ont peut-être vu le film
Benjamin Gates et le trésor des Templiers
avec Nicolas Cage.
Benjamin, le héros, part
à sa recherche aux États-Unis.
- Ça parait presque trop simple...
Alors, à Hollywood,
on a vraiment peur de rien,
parce que je préfère vous prévenir,
malgré certaines légendes,
il n'y a aucune chance
pour que le trésor se trouve de l'autre
côté de l'Atlantique.
Si ce trésor existe bien, c'est en France
qu'il se cache.
Mais nous y reviendrons tout à l'heure.
Avant de vous révéler le nom des lieux
où il pourrait se trouver,
il faut d'abord que je vous explique
qui étaient les Templiers.
Et si vous avez déjà joué au célèbre
jeu vidéo Assassin's Creed,
vous voyez forcément de quoi je parle.
Ce sont les moines soldats, ennemis
jurés de la confrérie des assassins.
Les Templiers, à l'époque,
ce sont nos fameux moines soldats,
mais aussi beaucoup de gens, combattant
ou non, qui ne sont pas des chevaliers.
Les chevaliers au combat portent la fameuse
tenue blanche à croix rouge,
mais cette dernière n'est absolument pas
systématique.
Souvent, les Templiers arborent également
leur étendard noir et blanc,
qu'on appelle le beaucéant.
Et pour différencier
les chevaliers des simples soldats,
c'est facile : les chevaliers sont en blanc,
les simples soldats en noir.
Du côté de l'équipement militaire,
je vous ai apporté quelques objets.
On a d'abord l'épée à une main
comme celle-ci,
puisque le modèle à deux mains
sera utilisé
uniquement après la fin des Templiers.
Un grand bouclier et une lance complètent
les armes de base et pour l'armure,
ils utilisent la cotte de mailles.
Pour le casque, au début,
on a ce genre là qui protège la tête
et le nez et, sur la fin, des heaumes fermés,
mais qui représentent finalement
une toute petite période de l'histoire
des Templiers.
Là encore,
il faut oublier les clichés d'Internet.
Mais le Templier, qui était-il vraiment ?
Leur histoire débute au Moyen-Orient,
au lendemain de la première croisade,
à la toute fin du XIᵉ siècle.
À cette époque, les chevaliers croisés
ont pris possession de Jérusalem
et ils n'ont qu'une obsession,
protéger la ville sainte
ainsi que l'ensemble des territoires
conquis par les chrétiens au Moyen-Orient :
des terres, des villes
et d'impressionnantes fortifications.
Ils se sont aussi donné pour mission
d'assurer la protection
des pèlerins qui se rendent à Jérusalem
pour se recueillir,
parce qu'à l'époque,
les routes sont pleines de dangers.
Pour mener à bien cette mission,
quelques chevaliers croisés décident
de fonder un ordre, l'Ordre du Temple.
Il se compose de chevaliers
qui ont pour particularité
d'être aussi des moines,
mais aussi de nombreux civils
et des combattants non religieux.
L'Ordre est officiellement reconnu
au Concile de Troyes en 1129.
Le premier grand maître
est Hugues de Payns,
un chevalier du nord de la France.
Au cours du XIIᵉ siècle,
les Templiers imposent leur présence
partout : dans les territoires contrôlés
par les chrétiens au Moyen-Orient
on l'a dit, mais aussi en Europe,
pour l'essentiel en France, en Angleterre
et un peu en Espagne.
Ces moines soldats deviennent très vite
une force politique
avec laquelle il faut compter.
Et ils n'hésitent pas à dépasser
le cadre originel de leur mission
en participant à de nombreuses batailles.
C'est par exemple
le cas de celle de Hattin en 1187.
Elle oppose les forces du royaume
de Jérusalem aux troupes de Saladin.
C'est une cuisante défaite
pour l'armée occidentale.
L'Ordre du Temple
est également devenu extrêmement riche
au fil du temps.
Les Templiers ont réussi à mettre en place
un gigantesque réseau commercial
et territorial.
Ils entretiennent des forteresses,
des châteaux
et des commanderies
qui leur rapportent beaucoup d'argent.
Les commanderies templières
sont des domaines
tenant à la fois du monastère
et de la ferme.
Elles sont réservées au personnel
militaire ou religieux et aux paysans
qui cultivent les terres du temps.
Rien qu'en France,
on en compte plusieurs centaines.
Elles leur rapporteraient énormément,
sous forme d'or,
de bijoux et de pierreries,
bien entendu, Et selon la légende,
ce fabuleux magot serait enfermé
dans de très nombreux coffres en bois.
Et tout cela, bien entendu, placés
sous bonne garde dans une pièce secrète
dont seul le grand maître de l'Ordre
des Templiers aurait la clé.
Bien sûr,
l'argent du temple ne sert pas à enrichir
personnellement nos Templiers
qui ont fait vœu de pauvreté.
Il permet d'entretenir leurs possessions,
les gens qui travaillent pour eux,
les actions en Terre sainte,
mais aussi à accorder des prêts.
L'Ordre fonctionne
comme une gigantesque banque
qui a la réputation de faire d'énormes
profits. Et en à peine 3 siècles,
les Templiers s'imposent
comme une des premières puissances
militaires et financières d'Occident.
Et ça, ça ne plaît pas à tout le monde.
Et à un homme en particulier,
très puissant, qui veut leur peau.
C'est le roi de France Philippe le Bel.
En ce tout début de XIVᵉ
siècle, c'est déjà un grand monarque.
En quelques années, il a su moderniser
la France et réformer son administration.
Il a aussi pris ses distances
avec l'Église qu'il juge trop puissante.
Les Templiers, qui sont soutenus
par le pape,
représentent donc une menace à ses yeux.
Enfin, ce qu'il convoite par dessus tout,
bien entendu, c'est leur immense fortune.
Pour mettre la main dessus,
il piège les Templiers.
Philippe le Bel accuse ces derniers de rites
obscènes et d'outrages envers le Christ.
Rien que ça, à l'époque,
c'est des accusations
qui sont absolument terribles.
Et le 13 octobre 1307,
il les fait arrêter.
La plupart des Templiers sont emprisonnés,
quelques-uns sont torturés
pour avouer leurs crimes supposés.
Évidemment, sous la torture,
on avoue un peu n'importe quoi.
L'Ordre, lui, est tout simplement supprimé,
ce qui permet à Philippe le Bel
de s'emparer
des très nombreuses possessions
des Templiers,
les commanderies et les terres.
De quoi renflouer
confortablement les caisses de l'État.
Toutefois, je vous le rappelle,
la légende raconte qu'une grande partie
du trésor des Templiers se trouverait
dans des coffres, beaucoup de coffres.
Or, ceux-ci sont introuvables.
Les moines chevaliers
croupissent en prison
pendant plusieurs années.
Et finalement, le 18 mars 1314, sept ans
après son arrestation,
leur chef Jacques de Molay
est conduit au bûcher.
Et ce jour-là,
un événement incroyable se serait produit :
au moment où les flammes ont commencé
à le dévorer,
Jacques de Molay
aurait lancé une terrible malédiction
à l'encontre de ceux
qui ont sali l'honneur des Templiers.
Le roi de France, bien entendu,
mais aussi le pape
Clément V qui n'a pas levé
le petit doigt pour les défendre.
Soyez tous maudits !
Jusqu'à la treizième génération de vos races !
Et bien,
aussi incroyable qu'il puisse paraître,
son vœu est rapidement exaucé.
Parce que le pape Clément V meurt
un mois plus tard, en avril 1314.
En novembre, c'est au tour de Philippe
le Bel.
Il passe l'arme à gauche à la suite
d'une étrange chute de cheval.
Il a à peine 46 ans.
Dans la foulée, son fils Louis X meurt prématurément
d'un coup de froid, à seulement 26 ans.
Puis c'est le petit Jean, dit Jean
le Posthume, censé prendre sa suite,
qui disparaît
alors qu'il n'a que 5 jours.
Son successeur disparaît avant ses 30 ans,
le suivant à 33.
Bref.
Le malheur frappe la famille royale
et lorsque Charles IV
passe l'arme à gauche,
il n'y a plus d'héritier mâle direct
pour occuper le trône de France.
Mais revenons à ce qui nous intéresse :
le fameux trésor contenu dans les coffres.
On raconte que,
juste avant leur arrestation,
les Templiers ont pris des dispositions
pour qu'il échappe au roi.
Plusieurs chariots
remplis d'or et de bijoux
auraient quitté la France pour l'Écosse,
un pays moins hostile.
Un document retrouvé dans les archives
du Vatican signale par exemple
qu'un Templier nommé Gérard de Villiers
se serait enfui avec 50 chevaux
et aurait pris la mer sur 18 galères
quand même.
D'autres sources mentionnent
que les coffres auraient été planqués
par les familles de certains membres
de l'Ordre, mais où ?
Alors, probablement dans les sous-sols d'un château,
d'une abbaye, voire dans un cimetière.
Les histoires mystérieuses
ne manquent pas,
mais cette histoire de cimetière
est revenue en 1885 grâce à Bérenger
Saunière, un prêtre qui officie à Rennes-le-Château,
dans le Languedoc.
Il aurait, selon
certains témoins, découvert le trésor
des Templiers
dans le cimetière du village.
De l'or, de l'or, de l'or.
Du jour au lendemain,
le curé se met à dépenser sans compter.
Il restaure le sanctuaire à grands frais,
achète plusieurs terrains et choque
sa hiérarchie par ses extravagances.
En France,
l'affaire fait la une des journaux.
Il faut attendre 1990 pour qu'un
historien français, Jean-Jacques
Bedu, prouve qu'en réalité, l'abbé
avait détourné de l'argent des messes.
Cette piste aboutit donc à une impasse.
En 1964, le ministre de la Culture,
André Malraux ordonne
également des fouilles archéologiques
au château de Gisors en Normandie.
La raison ?
Un ancien guide touristique prétend
y avoir découvert 19
sarcophages de pierre
qui pourraient abriter le fameux trésor.
L'hypothèse est crédible
car plusieurs membres du temple
y ont été emprisonnés au XIVᵉ siècle.
Jacques de Molay, lui-même le dernier
grand maître de l'Ordre,
en faisait d'ailleurs partie.
Mais après trois mois
d'efforts, c'est la déception.
On ne trouve absolument rien.
Tout au long du XXᵉ siècle,
la question du trésor refait régulièrement
surface.
Livres, films, séries...
Tout ça y fait régulièrement référence,
mais la légende perdure.
Et en 98, c'est le coup de théâtre !
On croit enfin avoir découvert le trésor
dans un domaine situé à Payns,
un village de l'Aube.
Un certain Bernard Delacourt
a déterré un lot de 708 pièces d'argent
datant de la fin du XIᵉ siècle.
Et il en est certain,
il a découvert le trésor des Templiers.
Pour valider son hypothèse,
il s'appuie sur un argument imparable :
le tout premier propriétaire de ce domaine
n'est autre qu'Hugues de Payns.
Vous vous souvenez, c'est le tout premier
grand maître de l'Ordre des Templiers.
Mais cette fois encore, c'est
une fausse piste.
Ces pièces d'or sont bien antérieures
à l'arrestation des Templiers.
Pas de chance !
Bon alors, ce trésor,
vous en pensez quoi, vous ?
Il existe ou pas finalement ?
Bon, si vous voulez mon avis,
toutes ces histoires de malédiction
et de trésor, et bah c'est du vent !
La fameuse malédiction
de Jacques de Molay
sur le bûcher, "Vous serez maudits !"
machin machin,
en réalité,
elle a été inventée de toutes pièces
en 1330, 16 ans après son exécution.
Elle ne deviendra célèbre que deux siècles
plus tard, à travers plusieurs auteurs
parce que les gens aimaient déjà
les histoires
un peu mystérieuses à cette époque.
Quant à la mort soudaine de Philippe
le Bel, un simple accident de cheval
qui lui aurait provoqué un choc à la tête
et une hémorragie cérébrale.
Celle du pape Clément V n'a
absolument rien de suspect non plus.
Il avait 50 ans et mourir à 50 ans
à l'époque, ça n'a rien d'étonnant.
Quant au successeur de Philippe
le Bel, disparu prématurément,
ça n'a rien de surprenant non plus.
Au Moyen-Âge, les gens pouvaient parfois
mourir assez jeune.
Et je vais peut-être vous décevoir,
mais il y a aussi de fortes chances
pour que ces fameux coffres
remplis à ras bord d'or
n'aient jamais existé.
C'est probablement une légende
qui a traversé le temps.
Comme je vous l'ai déjà un peu dit,
la richesse des Templiers résidait
principalement dans leurs possessions :
les commanderies, les forteresses,
les comptoirs commerciaux et tout ça,
c'est déjà Philippe
le Bel qui s'en était emparé.
Une chose est sûre,
il reste beaucoup à découvrir
sur les moines soldats
les plus célèbres de tous les temps.
Et les découvertes archéologiques
à ce sujet
seront des trésors pour la connaissance.
Mais voilà, cette légende du trésor des
Templiers, c'est déjà une belle histoire.
Et moi, j'adore les belles histoires.
Voilà les Épicurieuses et les Épicurieux,
la chasse au trésor est finie
pour aujourd'hui.
Et moi, j'ai rien trouvé
et je ne suis pas plus riche qu'avant !
Enfin, j'espère
que cette histoire vous a plu
et surtout indiquez en commentaire
les sujets histoire que vous aimeriez
que l'on traite. Sur ce, à très bientôt !